Este vídeo fue publicado el miércoles
por el gobierno serbio en las imágenes
las fuerzas de seguridad serbias meten
en un coche a tres policíascos hogares
según Belgrado estos agentes fuertemente
equipados fueron detenidos en el país a
pocos kilómetros de la frontera con
kosovo
debo decir que los miembros de nuestra
policía No entraron en el territorio de
kosovo y metoya
y único y su preclus los que violaron
los acuerdos internacionales son los
terroristas miembros de la policía
especial de kosovo
cosas que policía esta versión fue
inmediatamente desmentida por el Primer
Ministro kosovar que se refirió al
suceso en Facebook como un acto de
agresión para Cristina Serbia secuestró
a los policías cuando entraron en su
territorio
la policía o el ejército serbios
entraron unos 600 metros en el
territorio de la República de kosovo
se dividieron en varios grupos y
cruzaron la frontera alrededor de un
kilómetro
mil kilómetros
kosovo ha prohibido la entrada en su
territorio de vehículos con matrícula
Serbia el presidente serbio Alexander
acusó a pristina de querer provocar una
guerra está retórica bélica ilustra la
renovada atención entre Serbia y su
antigua provincia que se independizó en
2008 desde hace casi tres semanas se
producen enfrentamientos entre la cafor
la fuerza policial dirigida por la otan
y los serbios de kosovo los serbios
protestan contra el nombramiento de
alcaldes albaneses en ciudades del Norte
donde son mayoría